new england patriots have splurged this
week bringing in new players keeping old
players doing what they have to do to
improve a roster that was good enough
for bill belichick to will it to seven
and nine last year the improvements they
made this year miles i'll tell you it's
uh
i don't know how it's going to go but i
love the story let's delve into it a
little more with what's more likely
what's more likely for the patriots at
quarterback cam newton starting 10 or
more games for them or
jimmy garoppolo starting 10 or more
games for the san francisco 49ers
what about jimmy garoppolo starting 10
or more games for the new england
patriots because if that were an option
i still might go there i just i still
don't see cam newton being the starting
quarterback for that team for the entire
season maybe it's week one maybe they're
able to draft somebody and try to
develop them wherever they are in that
first round pecking order i just it's
hard for me to think that based on the
way we saw cam newton play last year
where yes he was effective at times but
mostly with his legs that that's still
the way they want to play here in 2021 i
just i don't think that cam newton is
going to start 10 plus games unless they
don't have really any options so i guess
to answer the question i think it's more
likely that jimmy garoppolo starts 10 or
more games for the 49ers the 49ers were
very interested in mitchell trubisky
which intrigued me from the perspective
of what it would mean to garoppolo when
trubisky goes to buffalo and joe flacco
lands on the radar screen for the 49ers
that's good news for jimmy garoppolo as
it relates to holding on to his starting
job at least until there's a chance this
is all a big ruse until they get sam
darnold from the jets because i still
think that is a possibility for the
49ers it could be they get through round
one of the draft and then go get darnold
from the jets if the jets take a kyle
wilson for example with the second
overall pick i'm going to say it's more
likely that newton starts 10 or more for
the patriots i i yeah they could end up
with jimmy garoppolo back they could end
up with marcus mariota who's been asked
to take a major pay cut by the las vegas
raiders and if he would get cut maybe he
makes his way to new england and that's
an intriguing depth chart with newton
and mariota but i'll say it's more
likely newton starts 10 or more simply
because i don't have faith in garoppolo
staying healthy he's missed 23 games
over the last three years all right
what's more likely russell wilson starts
fewer than 16 games for the seahawks by
the way he's never missed a game in his
nine year career or mitchell trubisky
starts at least one game for the buffalo
bills what's more likely
i think it's the mitchell trubisky would
start one game for the bills and it's
only because josh allen plays in a way
that is a little bit dangerous for a qb
sometimes you know he throws his body
around he's willing to sacrifice and lay
out for different things so i i would
have to say that it's going to be
mitchell trubisky but that's why they
brought him there so that if you know
something happens to josh allen then he
can come in mitchell trubisky can and
still at least run the offense pretty
effectively that's why they brought him
there and i think that look russell
wilson
is going to be the seahawks quarterback
this year at least it seems that way
right now and if he's out there then
he's gonna play he's shown some real
toughness in the past i don't see him
missing a game this year for them
see that's where this question becomes
difficult because it's either gonna be
16 or none for russell wilson in seattle
right the door not entirely shut on a
tray just because the bears made an
effort to get him that
was not nearly good enough doesn't mean
there isn't someone else lurking waiting
for the right time to make their move
doesn't mean the seahawks have
completely slammed the door on the
possibility of trading and because
it could be that the situation isn't
sustainable with russell wilson in
seattle the things he said several weeks
ago can they mend those fences can they
compartmentalize are they willing to go
through a season that would entail
plenty of distractions from
media during press conferences and
questions from that are asked of pete
carroll and questions asked of russell
wilson if the team encounters any
adversity so this one's tough for me
i'm gonna go
that it's more likely
that wilson starts fewer than 16 simply
because there's still a lingering
possibility he starts zero all right
that's i'm still i'm i'm just
look i'm not
i i love a good story and i still think
the better story is another year of
russell wilson in seattle with all the
dysfunction that may arise and then we
trade him next year next year the the a
topic can be where does russell wilson
go after a year of chaos in seattle so
that's kind of what i'm rooting for now
i always root for chaos too as long as
nobody gets hurt and this situation
doesn't seem like anybody's getting hurt
just gives us more things to talk about
i love it chaos is the latter
all right chaos in chicago chaos in
washington andy dalton orion fitzpatrick
which one is more likely to still be the
starting quarterback
come december
oh boy uh
ryan fitzpatrick i think
but also oh no it's actually andy dalton
uh it depends on if washington takes a
quarterback
i mean as you love to say if it's magic
can become fits tragic oh so quickly
um and it just seems to inevitably
happen so i don't know what the depth
chart's going to look like behind him
but if washington takes a qb which i
really think that they probably should
then that qb in theory could supplant
him much like tua did last year in miami
uh but then ryan fitzpatrick could still
be the relief pitcher and the relief
pitcher sees seems to be so your answer
is
i think it's andy dalton i guess is
still the starting quarterback in
december but i don't feel good about
either of those options
as written the question implies that
it's an unbroken chain of starting
quarterback still the starter in
december if that's the way it's
interpreted then i say dalton because
while there's a chance fitzpatrick will
be the starter again in december he
ain't making it 16 games fits tragic
will make an appearance at some point
and he'll either be injured or injured
whatever the case may be ron rivera will
have seen enough and it'll be kyle allen
or taylor heineken until he's seen
enough of them and then it's back to
ryan fitzpatrick so if it's an unbroken
chain i say andy dalton is more likely
to still be the starter in december i i
just and this is the the the
the tendency in me to push back against
the popular narrative the popular
narrative that andy dalton sucks i think
is wrong and so i'm going to push back
against it and i i think the bears may
be on to something here especially with
as we discussed last hour the reduced
expectations so i i hate i hate the
thought
as a a childhood vikings fan i hate the
thought that i'm actually going to be
rooting for the bears this year
well you know if you don't love me now
you'll never love me again i can still
hear them saying they will never break
the chain i don't gotta throw some
fleetwood mac in there you just kept
talking about the chain man
well done well i like that and uh shows
uh shows that you know more bands than
the one that you mentioned last hour
that i've already forgotten what was it
bad bad good bad bad not bad
bad badly roy brown good
bad bad
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports